We've talked about the three factors of authentication, authentication by knowledge, authentication
by ownership. We've talked about the three factors of authentication, authentication
by knowledge, authentication by ownership, and authentication by characteristic. Let's dig
into the first two, authentication by knowledge, and authentication by ownership.
We're going to start with authentication by knowledge. Authentication by knowledge means
something that you know. So what are some examples of that? Well, things like passwords,
past phrases, security questions, things like that. What's a past phrase, specifically? Well,
a past phrase is meant to be a sentence or a lyric from a song, something that's multiple words
long that you can easily remember. And so the idea behind it is to make a password that's very
long but still easy to remember. So that's a past phrase. And what are security questions? Well,
that's things like, what's your favorite color pumpkin or why do whales smell funny? Things
like that. The questions that you would remember the answers to. Maybe those are good ones.
Now let's talk about authentication by ownership, which is something that you have. One of the most
common types of authentication by ownership is often referred to as OTP or one-time passwords.
These are devices that generate one-time passwords that are only used once. And there's two types
of one-time password generators. There's soft tokens and hard tokens. Software, soft tokens
implies that what's generating the one-time passwords is software. Whereas hard tokens means that
the device that's generating the tokens is a piece of hardware, like an RSA ID key. Let me show
you an example of a soft token. So on my iPhone here, to log into all my super secure accounts and
so forth, I use the Google authenticator. And as you can see, please not log into my accounts. Here are
the one-time passwords that are generated for a bunch of the services that I access. And as you'll
see in a moment here, these passwords will expire and then new ones will be generated. That's why they're
called one-time passwords. The other example of authentication by ownership is things called smart
cards or memory cards. And we'll get into those in a moment. First, let's spend a little more
time on one-time passwords. Because there's actually two ways that we can generate these one-time
passwords, asynchronous and synchronous. So what's the difference? Here's how asynchronous one-time
passwords work. The user will start by saying to the server, I would like to authenticate.
The server will respond back with a challenge. And it's basically just a code. The user will then
have a device. And they have to challenge that or they have to type that challenge into their
device, type that code into their device. When they type that code in, their device will generate
a response through some sort of software mechanism. It'll generate a response and show it on the
screen. The user then has to type that response back into their system. And that response is then
sent back to the server. So asynchronous implies that there's a challenge and then a response back.
And so it's pretty rare to see these. One perfect example of this is they're the Bloomberg
terminal access cards. It's really cool how these work actually. I've seen a couple of them.
So what the way this works is you've got this card. And on the back of the card, there's actually
a little camera. And when the user wants to authenticate to their very expensive Bloomberg terminal,
they actually hold the card up to their screen. And the screen will flash black and white really
quickly. And it's actually sending a code a challenge through the screen to the card. The cards
camera picks that up and then generates the appropriate response. And it shows it on the screen.
The user then has to type in that response along with their other authentication information
in order to get access. So that's an example of a asynchronous system. Pretty rare to see those.
Now what about synchronous systems? The reason we call these synchronous is because the device
and the server are in sync. They're generating the same one-time password every 30 seconds or
60 seconds, whatever it happens to be. So how do synchronous devices work? Well, it would be just
like what I showed you on my phone here or an RSA ID key. You've got a device either a soft token
or a hard token that's generating a one-time password all the time. And whenever you want to log in,
you simply read the one-time password off your device, type into the computer system,
and send that to the server. The server is in sync with the device. It's generating the same
one-time password at the same time. And so if the one-time password that you type in is the same
one that it's generated for this period of time, then it will authenticate you.
Now let's talk about smart cards and memory cards. And actually, a perfect way to talk about this
is by looking at a credit, a modern day credit card. Because it's both a smart card and a memory
card. And by the way, this is my real credit card. So I've blacked it out. Please don't
steal my card. Now, how does a modern day credit card demonstrate both smart card and memory card?
Let's start with a simple aspect, memory card. And memory card implies that it's just some memory,
just some data that's stored. And if you look on the back of the credit card, and I'm intentionally
covering up my CVV number here, if you look on the back of my credit card, there's a magnetic strip
here. That magnetic strip just contains some data, some memory. So when you swipe this card through
a reader, it would read that memory and then generate and that data that's read off of the memory
area is what would allow your credit card transaction to go through. And this is what made older style
credit cards so incredibly easy to copy because all you have to do is exactly copy this data,
and as long as you use that data off of there, you could make a credit card payment.
Modern credit cards don't use just memory. They are actually smart cards. So if you look at this
little piece right here on my credit card, this is actually a little computer chip underneath here.
And this is where we have to talk about, there's two types of smart cards that are under known as
contact and contact lists. So contact implies that when you put this card into a reader,
this chip area here has to actually make contact with the reader. And it's through these metal
contacts here that the chip is actually powered. And the way this works in smart cards is that
when you plug the card in to a reader, there's a bit of communication that goes back and forth between
the card and the reader to process the credit card transaction. And what's important about this is
that the numbers that come off of this card are unique every time. So you can't just copy the data
off of here and make a copy of the credit card. It's more intelligent than that. So that's contact.
It's the same underlying concept of a smart card in that with contact lists, there's a little radio
receivaring here. And when you get this near to a reader, the reader is constantly sending out
strong pulses. And that pulse will be read by the card. And importantly, that pulse is powerful
enough to actually power the card in here or to power the little chip in here for a moment so
that it can perform some calculations and then send a signal back to the reader. So all of this is
actually powered by pulses being sent out by the reader, powers the chip, comes up with a number,
responds back to the reader, and that's how contact lists works. Both examples, contact and contact
lists of smart cards, which is a method of authentication by ownership.